jo was geht mein Name ist t tesso und
ich habe eine Frage an dich also ich
habe dich gefragt wie stellst du dir
dein Leben ungefähr in so 10 Jahren vor
möchtest du uns immer noch entertainen
rappen wie auch immer oder möchtest du
mit deiner Familie das heißt Kind Frau
in einem Hausleben alleine weg von der
Medienwelt dann Ruhe
haben ja das war meine
Frage coole Frage muss ich sagen äh
natürlich will man irgendwann seine Ruhe
haben ich merke das jetzt schon ab und
zu dass ich sag okay guck mal heute
gibt's nichts heute ist Sonntag ich
mache mein Handy aus Internet aus und
will mal ein bisschen chillen
andererseits bin ich eine Rampensau und
ein Entertainer Schwein und irgendwas
werde ich mit der Entertainment Branche
glaube ich immer zu tun haben ob vor der
Kamera hinter der Kamera was auch immer
ich versuche ja auch meine fernsehsachen
irgendwie bisschen unter in den Griff zu
kriegen und hoffentlich bieten sich da
für mich verschiedene Möglichkeiten die
man dann halt auch im Alter äh
praktizieren kann aber noch bin ich ja
27 also so alt bin ich auch nicht auch
wenn ich schon lange dabei bin ich bin
halt ziemlich neu dazu gestoßen ziemlich
jung dazuestoßen und ich denke so 10
Jahre kann ich noch rappen und was
danach passiert schauen wir
mal